please welcome the glamorous film and
recording star Jennifer Lopez
the Academy award-winning lyricist Ira
Gershwin wrote this about a love affair
but he could have been writing about a
song in the movies our romance won't end
on a sorrowful note though in the
morning you will be gone the song may be
ended but as a songwriter wrote the
melody lingers on and on for Best
Original Song the nominees are
from Kate and Leopold until music and
lyric by Sting from the Lord of the
Rings the Fellowship of the Ring may it
be music and lyric by Enya Nicky Ryan
and Roma Ryan
from monsters incorporated if I didn't
have you music and lyric by Randy Newman
from Pearl Harbor there you'll be music
and lyric by Diane Warren from Vanilla
Sky Vanilla Sky
music and lyric by Paul McCartney and
the Oscar goes to Randy Newman for if I
did
Randy Newman has 16 Academy Award
nominations and now
whoa
thank you
I don't uh uh I don't want your pity
I want to thank first of all the music
branch for giving me so many chances to
be humiliated over the years I have
nothing I'm absolutely astounded that I
won for this though the the picture
deserves recognition they made four
pictures in a row that were good at
Peter where did that once but I can't
remember another instance exactly all
for the Pixar Disney movies were good oh
wait are you really gonna play in four
seconds
go play it's been so long I have
something that I would like to thank
milosz formative Berenson no I'm very
grateful I would like to thank John
Lasseter Pete docter all these musicians
many of whom have worked for me a number
of times and may not again uh walking
out here and having someone this
beautiful giving award I'll never get to
heaven but that's as close as you get I
think thanks very much I'm thrilled